all right what's up everybody my name is
Alan dragu and today I'm going to give
you 10 mistakes that beginner
copywriters make and how to avoid them
right in this video for free so before
we jump in please make sure to like And
subscribe to the channel and the video
helps me know that you find this content
really valuable and that you want me to
continue creating content for free just
for you all right let's Dive Right In
and bullet these babies out and no
particular order find the one that
resonates with you but the first one is
going to be number one you don't know
who you're writing to this might
actually be one of the biggest ones is
that people are trying to write for
everybody especially in the beginning
you're not sure who you're writing to
and you're just writing copy but it is
more important that you understand your
target audience when you start writing
otherwise you don't know what makes them
tick okay copyrighting is more about
human psychology than the writing itself
in fact Ben one of the most famous
copywriters in the world uses as an
example where he says think like a fish
not a Fisher Min okay copywriters often
think like Fisher men they're trying to
hook somebody instead of like the fish
what does the fish like where does the
fish spend time what's the environment
of the ocean that the fish flounders
around in okay you have to understand
the fish more than being a fisherman and
you'll be able to catch more fish
because what is copywriting about you're
selling something and if you don't know
who you're selling to well then you're
just writing content and tweets and
posts online that people will like which
is fine but that's not copyrighting
copyrighting is selling something to
someone who are you selling to go figure
that out problem number two is fancy
language all right you have to unlearn
almost everything that you learn in
school maybe you went through middle
school and high school and your teachers
told you to write these long essays with
these thick paragraphs and multi-
syllable words and lots of adverbs and
adjectives and all this stuff well that
stuff does not work in copyrighting okay
you have to realize that most people
read out of fourth fifth and sixth grade
level average being fifth grade level
and so a great tool that I've used in
the past I don't really use it anymore
but I used it in the past when I was
starting out is Hemingway okay Hemingway
will actually highlight your sentences
and tell you what grade level you're
actually riding at and a lot of people
like to write at 8 n 10th grade level
just to sound fancy and sophisticated
well people don't buy fancy and
sophisticated they actually buy stupid
simple that's what they buy and so you
need to bring your fancy language down
and make it into two syllables one
syllable as much as possible everyday
common language that your target
audience your fish like to use and this
is the better way to write copy beginner
mistake number three is weak headlines
okay headlines are what gets read by 80%
of the people okay 80% of the people
only read the headlines and not any
further so only 20% read the actual body
copy which means you need to spend 80%
of your time I'm crafting that headline
and I do have a video on irresistible
subject lines which will actually
translate very well to writing headlines
whether it's subject lines for emails or
headlines for tweets or headlines for
articles headlines for sales letters
it's a great way to write headlines so
you can go check that video out I'll put
it in the description below if you want
to do that but a weak headline one that
doesn't have any power words there's no
curiosity there's no teup to his story
it's not specific on who it's for has no
promise no proof all of those things is
not going to get the readership that you
want and in fact I do a practice where I
write three to five headlines for
everything before I pick one whether
it's for an email a tweet a YouTube
video just like this one I write three
to five headlines and say okay which one
do I like best that will actually get
you really good at writing headlines
fast because you're writing a ton of
them for what you're doing and naturally
you're going to get better over time
mistake number four is copying your
competitors in your industry all right
so this one is very very interesting
because I'm actually not against like
swiping and and having a swipe file and
having a forms of inspiration but what
beginners do a lot of times is they will
literally take the way somebody writes
or take the offer that they have or the
pricing that they have and they'll
literally word for word copy it or
they'll copy and paste it into their own
environment which beyond the plagiarism
and the stealing and things like that
it's just a dumb mistake because it's
not going to work for your people again
this is thinking like a fisherman and
not a fish who you're riding to is very
different than who other people are
riding to and so when you swipe tactics
like word for word never blatantly swipe
anyone you can swipe a salesletter read
it enjoy it get inspiration from it and
then understand what would work in your
Market in your industry and what
wouldn't work and then apply your own
tactics for your own people to think
like them as fish right they are the
fish what do they like okay other people
are fishing for other styles of fish so
blatantly swiping not going to work
mistake number five is never telling
stories okay especially right in the
back copywriters are trying to like give
value make a promise show the proof in
fact you guys should show more proof but
all of these things right you're trying
to like do all the copyrighting
Frameworks and and you don't really tell
the story that supports the whole thing
whether it's online on Twitter or a
medium or a sales letter or emails it's
just like value value value value value
well value is a commodity okay anybody
could put value together if I wanted
value i' go to chat gbt right now and
tell them to give me 10 books that I
should read because I'm 31 years old or
whatever crap is getting posted nowadays
but telling stories is unique telling
stories is your own thing in fact nobody
can swipe a story so if you tell a story
from your life that's personal to you
and you tie it to your product that
makes it so much more powerful because
stories are interesting people are
naturally drawn into them and they
actually cannot be swiped and so instead
of giving value I would dive in to be
more story framework based problem
number six is focusing on the product
instead of the problem okay this
happened to me the other day I actually
got a letter from this uh Lawn Care like
service products thing it sent me
something in the mail and I opened it
and I read this little brochure because
I have some lawn stuff I need to take
care of I I want thicker grass I got
some crab grass in there I got all kinds
of stuff just kind of floating around I
got some weeds I need to take care of so
I was like interested in the stuff that
they were selling I open up the brochure
and all it talks about is their product
we use these styles of chemicals it'll
last you this long it'll like we use
this formula this famous formula and and
all the so all it did was talk about the
product but I don't care about your
product can you solve my problem that is
a huge huge part where copywriters often
are more interested in the thing they
sell than the people they are selling to
and that's a big big mistake again we
come back to it thinking like a fish not
a fisherman you need to focus on
people's problems not your product your
product is just a binary means of
helping them solve their problem because
if you don't solve a problem or talk
about their problem they don't give two
rips about your product problem number
seven that beginner copywriters make is
ignoring the data this is a huge one
that I still don't understand to this
day okay it is so easy to go look at
your Google analytics go look at your
Twitter analytics to go look at your
medium analytics and start assessing
what works and what doesn't work okay
what headlines get read what products
sell in what emails right you can go
look at those things and start to
understand okay people open this
headline why do they open this headline
so much more or people bought way more
from this email instead of that email
why did they buy way more from this
email instead of that email okay and
some of you will say well I don't have
analytics to look at I'm too new or
people don't like my posts or uh people
don't read my emails yes you do okay
every piece of thing that you've ever
posted has analytics even if it's small
analytics so if you tweet one time and
most of your tweets get one like but
then you put this one tweet that gets
two likes okay well that got 100% more
likes than all of your other tweets so
that tells you that twice as many people
like that one even if it's just from one
to two it's still twice as many people
so there's something about that tweet or
that email gets opened up by 10 more
people instead of the other five usual
people okay any set of data whether
small or big will tell you something is
working or something is not working and
the most important thing you could do as
a beginner copywriter is identify the
winners identify the losers kill the
losers and double down on the winners
mistake number eight is your formatting
sucks this this is a big one because
copyrighting is like food people eat
with their eyes and they read with their
eyes as well well they obviously read
with their eyes but but you get what I'm
saying people read a natural flow so if
you have just one massive slab of
copy all the way down the page that is a
very intimidating way to write copy it's
not aesthetically pleasing and so
formatting is one of the simplest ways
to get your copyri more okay using uh H2
H1 H3 Style headlines to kind of break
up the text using single line spacing to
kind of help break up some of the flow
using Rhythm and like one sentence three
sentence one sentence okay 131 1315 like
there's ways to break up your Rhythm to
be able to make your copy more appealing
okay you can use bullets you can use uh
ascending copy wordss like long sentence
medium sentence short sentence there's
all kinds of ways to do your formatting
and in fact uh I pride myself in a lot
of my formatting that you could actually
go to Allen dru.com sign up for my daily
newsletter read the exact way that I
format my emails all the time and so you
see how I make even 500w a thw emails
flow like the Waters of Aspen right you
want it to just GL you want people to
just Glide down the page in fact Joe
sugerman calls this the slippery slope
okay you want to grease the slide for
people and formatting does that
formatting greases the slide for people
to slide right down you don't want them
like climbing down a mountain of words
okay that seems like a lot of work so
your formatting is going to get you a
lot more read time copyrighting mistake
number nine is rambling okay rambling is
one of the biggest things that beginner
copywriters do they just ramble ramble
ramble and they have all this content in
there and what's actually true is that
copyrighting isn't the more you write
the better it's actually I literally
can't say less than this okay you have
to remember you are competing with like
Tik Tock attention spans okay people are
addicted to YouTube and Instagram reals
that reading your copy could be a lot of
mental energy to that and so having a
rambled paragraph could absolutely lose
somebody in a fraction of a second and
so you have to make sure that every
single sentence that you have in your
copy is the reason to read the next
sentence okay so you need to edit
ruthlessly to make sure you don't have
any rambling that every sentence is a
reason to read the next and the last
copyrighting mistake that beginners make
is features over
benefits this is most famously made by
Steve Jobs when he released the iPod
this is the most simple example of what
this is okay in about 2003 2004 when he
released the iPod uh everybody had their
own MP3 players and they were touting
things like one gigabyte of storage or
like 24 Hertz or like right they were
talking about the features of the
product themselves but what Steve Jobs
did was he turned those features into
the benefits of the user again thinking
about about the fish not the fishermen
okay what do the fish want what do your
people actually want well they don't
care about 5 GB of storage or one
gigabyte of storage and so what Steve
Jobs did is said instead of the storage
what does the storage get them it gets
them the ability to put a thousand songs
on their iPod and that iPod is small
enough to fit in your pocket which came
out to the very famous line a th000
songs in your pocket which outsold all
the iPods and it out sold every
competitor and that is the power of a
benefit over a feature if Apple would
have just put 5 GB of storage on the ad
no one would have cared because that
doesn't translate to them they don't
care about 5 GB of storage but he wrote
a th000 songs in your pocket that's what
people care about carrying music around
wherever they go and enjoying that time
so that's it that is the 10 beginner
copyrighted mistakes that you can avoid
to have Banger copy sell more stuff and
enjoy your copyrighting career for
decades to come and if you enjoyed this
video I would ask that you would please
hit like on the video and that you would
subscribe to the channel to let me know
that you want more free content like
this and lastly before you go I do have
a free gift for you if you haven't
already grabbed it copyrighting catalyst
is in the description below it is 63
cash Cal copyrighting tips for you to
study every single day it's a short
little lesson that you can read in 90
seconds or less 63 of them to Skyrocket
even triple quadruple your copyrighting
income in no time it is free just put
your email in below and you'll enjoy it
thanks so much and I'll catch you on the
next
one that was a good one you want to do a
bonus tip number 11 copyrighted mistake
that beginners make they talk more about
copy than they actually write copy that
is one woo that is one that online is
just absolutely prevailing I see so many
tweets copy this copy that I'm favorite
copywriter all these things but I'm like
dude where's your copy I don't like do
you post copy do you have copy I've
never read copy that you've ever posted
so how about you write some freaking
copy that'll help you a ton